un pequeño milagro en medio de la
tragedia los equipos de rescate lograron
sacar con vida de entre los escombros a
una bebé que nació durante el temblor la
pequeña lucha por recuperarse en el
hospital pero sus padres y cuatro
hermanos desplazados internos de
teiresor Siria no sobrevivieron
encontramos los cuerpos de los padres
uno al lado del otro oímos un sonido
mientras excabábamos antes no íbamos
ningún sonido pero cuando acabamos más
lo oímos cavamos y limpiamos el polvo
encontramos a la bebé todavía atada por
el cordón umbilical
sin embargo en la misma localidad
yandaris son siendo los que lloran a sus
familiares atrapados sin vida entre las
ruinas algunos mantienen la esperanza
Cualquier minuto cuenta lo saben estos
improvisados rescatistas procedentes de
it estamos aquí para ayudar no hay
estado no hay equipo para ayudar a la
gente no hay excavadoras ni equipo duro
Todo lo hacemos con nuestras manos
familias enteras siguen atrapadas bajo
los escombros
también en el lado Turco los servicios
de Socorro apoyados por el ejército
buscan a los desaparecidos caras de
emoción cuando una persona es encontrada
con vida como el pequeño muhamed
refugiado sirio en Turquía pero no hay
tiempo para celebraciones todavía Son
miles los que siguen desaparecidos los
que han logrado sobrevivir a los sismos
se enfrentan a las gélidas temperaturas
con improvisados fuegos sin un hogar
donde refugiarse
Aquí no hay nadie todos estamos
condenados Este es el orden que tenemos
aquí en Turquía Esto no es lo que
esperábamos del Estado no importa cuán
grande haya sido el terremoto era
necesaria la movilización de todas las
personas
decidia Turquía Son miles las historias
de vidas truncadas y apagadas por los
terremotos mientras la población espera
la llegada de ayuda internacional con el
anhelo de volver a un hogar Pese a que
las autoridades se advierten que la
reconstrucción será larga